je sais pas je ne sais pas si je suis un
homme d'action réflexion
en tout cas depuis quelques semaines je
suis dans l'action avec isabelle le
callennec avec bien d'autres qui en
bretagne vers le faire bouger les choses
et on va y arriver parce qu'on veut y
arriver
merci nicolas de m'avoir accordé sa
confiance pour mener ce combat qui est
le combat de ma vie
il combat de ma vie parce que cette
région j'y suis attaché elle a une très
forte personnalité
j ai toutes mes racines j'ai décidé d'y
élever mes enfants j'ai décidé d'y faire
ma vie j'ai décidé de me battre pour
elle elle le vaut bien
comme on dit parfois dans la publicité
donc ce combat on le mène on le mène de
manière on ne peut plus déterminée
contre un concurrent qui a pour lui la
presse nationale dans des proportions
étonnantes plus qu'étonnante contre un
concurrent qui est perçu chez eux en
bretagne puisqu'il n'avait pas d'autres
éventualités comme une forme de de
sainte-rita c'est à dire la sainte qui
s'occupe des causes désespérées pour
essayer de sauver la bretagne
socialistes contre un concurrent qui a
démontré sa capacité d'adaptation
il a commencé maui fini marchand d'armes
c'est pas mal donc on est dedans on est
dedans et on y va et je voudrais
développer un sujet qui parle breton
le breton c'est un homme libre qui est
attachée à la propriété qui veut accéder
à la propriété
c'était le cas il ya encore quelques
temps c'était le gars grâce en
particulier pour les ouvriers au régime
sur les heures supplémentaires que notre
gouvernement sous l'autorité nicolas
sarkozy à des mises en place ceux ci
étaient supprimés et très clairement
depuis 2012
on a assisté à un effondrement de la
construction les choses sont très
simples
en 2011 27 mille logements ou maison
ouverts à la construction en 2014 17000
on a perdu 10
logement le vrai sujet c'est de
permettre à ces bretons de réaliser leur
rêve de gagner un peu en sécurité aussi
chacun le vit sur son territoire de
retraite sont modestes mais quand
l'autre était propriétaire de sa propre
maison
il est quand même un peu épargner qu'en
plus il doit payer sa location
c'est très redoutable donc relancer la
construction de logements relancer cette
forme d'habitat les socialistes ni cette
difficulté comme dans beaucoup de
domaines ils sont dans le déni nous on
va faire en sorte que les familles
puissent avoir un petit plus pour
accéder à la propriété sous forme d'un
prêt à taux zéro régional qui permettra
à tout à chacun d'avoir un petit plus
déjà gêné gauthier avec les différents
réseaux bancaires qui pourront
constituer les guichets qui seront
ouverts aux uns et aux autres
cette possibilité elle doit être ouverte
c'est aussi l'occasion de relancer tout
un secteur dont la crise est à la fois
considérable et relativement discrète
parce que ces gens là font font pas
parler de tout ce secteur du bâtiment
donc relancer la construction relancer
la construction dans nos villes dans nos
villes intermédiaires dans nos villes
moyennes dans le monde rural faire en
sorte que tout un chacun puisse élever
ses enfants dans un cadre qui est à lui
et qu'il est ce petit élément de
sécurité qui soit un plus et puis aussi
permettre à ces gens de vivre de vivre
de circuler tu l'a très bien dit
dominique on a abandonné nos secteurs
routiers un chiffre très simple la
région bretagne prend aux automobilistes
sous forme de l'impôt sur les cartes
grises sous forme d complément d'impôt
sur les pelles et le pétrole plus de 300
millions d'euros et restitue péniblement
15 millions d'euros sur des chantiers
routiers
c'était le cas en tout cas l'an dernier
vous voyez bien que cette politique de
la vache à lait à l'égard du concitoyen
automobilistes
elle est inadmissible
nous devons la dénoncer nous devons
faire en sorte que les uns et les autres
puissent permettre d'accéder à la
propriété de vivre de circuler des
transports publics en particulier dans
nos secteurs ruraux même s'il progresse
ne sont pas toujours à la hauteur du
besoin
je pense en particulier à tous ceux qui
doivent se lever tôt pour prendre leur
voiture pour aller à leur travail
et puis le travail il faut que vous
sachiez que la bretagne est la région
qui a le plus perdu en terme d' apprenti
et d'apprentissage la plus le plus perdu
de toutes les régions de france
nous étions un pic de 15000 apprentis y
en nous sommes tombés à peine plus de
10000 apprentis y ont bien ça il faut
relancer cela ça implique des efforts à
l'égard des chefs d'entreprise ça ou
pique aussi un effort de conviction à
l'égard des jeunes qui vont vers
l'apprentissage
il faut que nous sachions les aider ces
jeunes apprentis
ils connaissent un problème très
particulier de mobilité parce qu'ils
vivent à un endroit lors cfa est un
autre endroit
et puis l'entreprise ou à force de temps
et de patience ils ont obtenu le contrat
d'apprentissage ce peut être encore un
troisième endroit d'où l'idée
systématiquement de concourir au
financement du permis de conduire qui
leur permettra d'accéder plus facilement
à sept possibilités d'apprentissage
et puis il faut aussi convaincre
convaincre la colle apprentissage est
une bonne chose
c'est pour ça que dans notre plan nous
prévoyons très clairement de donner la
possibilité on n'a pas la possibilité
d'obliger de données possibilité à tous
les enseignants d enseignement
professionnel des enseignements généraux
de pratiquer un stage dans une
entreprise et en particulier dans les
entreprises qui sont susceptibles
d'accueillir des jeunes de façon à ce
que ces sondes enseignants qui sont
aussi des prescripteurs pour les jeunes
il puisse faire tomber un peu un certain
nombre d'à priori et savoir expliquer à
leur retour à leur jeune que
l'entreprise c'est une occasion non
seulement de gagner sa vie mais c'est
une occasion de promotion c'est une
occasion d'initiative
ces salles nous voulons faire en
bretagne c'est pour ça que nous nous
battons avec toute la détermination que
l'on connaît parfois aux gens de l'ouest
et aux celtes en particulier nous
voulons démontrer ce faisant quand
de bons breton de bons français de bons
européens est en tout cas qu'on peut
gagner